und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Marie taslomka guten Abend der
gillamos Montag ist ja so etwas wie der
politische Aschermittwoch nur im
September jedenfalls hat der historische
Jahrmarkt vor den Toren der Altstadt von
abens Berges geschafft weit mehr als
eine niederbayerische Karussell und
bierzeltveranstaltung zu werden nicht
jedes Jahr gleichermaßen bedeutend aber
diesmal schaut natürlich die ganze
Republik hin wie tritt Hubert Aiwanger
auf was sagt Markus Söder über Aiwanger
was sagt Friedrich Merz darüber wie
Söder mit der cause iwange umgegangen
ist und was sagen alle anderen
das sind die vordergründigen Fragen aber
es geht natürlich um mehr wo jetzt zu
Lande Toleranzgrenzen verlaufen und wie
sich die Union nicht nur die CSU in
diesem und künftigen Wahlkämpfen
aufstellt Beobachtungen dazu von Zelt
die hampelampel
die schlechteste Regierung die
Deutschland je hatte wir werden von
Wahnsinnigen regiert servus
killerballs willkommen im Bierzelt wo
das derbe schon immer politisch korrekt
war Markus Söder hat sich für Taktik
entschieden nicht für Haltung im
mikrokosmosilamos zeichnet sich heute ab
wie dieser bayerische Wahlkampf in den
nächsten Wochen laufen könnte die einen
wollen über die ampelparteien Reden die
ampelparteien über Hubert Aiwanger
der redet heute eine Stunde lang die
flugblattaffäre erwähnt er mit keinem
Wort anders als in den letzten Tagen
inszeniert sich einfacher heute nicht
als Opfer einer Kampagne andere
übernehmen das für ihn
eiwanger gefällt sich in der Pose des
volkstribuns und er hält es für seine
Leistung dass die AFD in Bayern
verhältnismäßig klein ist
[Musik]
Spalten bis hin zu einer Situation der
Regierungsunfähigkeit und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir den Menschen in
der politischen Mitte ein Angebot machen
ein Angebot der vernünftigen Politik
Aiwanger als Mann der Mitte kaum zu
glauben finden Sie bei der bayerischen
Opposition
ist ein rechtspopulistischer
Geisterfahrer darf nicht länger die Hand
am Lenkrad des Freistaats Bayern haben
ich bin überzeugt dass gerade bei uns im
katholischen Altbayern doch gilt dass
jedem ruhigen Sünder Vergebung zu Teil
werden kann aber entscheidend ist eben
der Reue gesünder für Markus Söder ist
seine Entscheidung für Aiwanger heute
nicht mehr der Rede wert auch hier im
zählt der CSU übernimmt dieses Thema ein
anderer gerade in den letzten Tagen hat
er eine Aufgabe zu lösen gehabt Markus
die ich finde die hast du bravourös
gelöst sehr gut genauso war es richtig
dass so zu machen
kein Blick zurück das ist jetzt so das
Agenda dafür ein Blick recht weit in die
Zukunft
die Ampel wird das Jahr 2025 nicht mehr
erfolgreich als Regierung beschreiten
liebe Freunde die lösen wir gemeinsam
Abholzen gegen Berlin darauf Fuß zu das
Wahlkampf die Erzählung vom
erfolgreichen ampelfreien Süden ist
seine größte Stärke dass er dafür
einwanger braucht könnte sich als seine
größte Schwäche erweisen
wie Vladimir putinen den Getreidehandel
als Waffe einsetzt konnte man sich
letzte Nacht wieder einmal ansehen als
seine Armee die ukrainischen Häfen an
der Donau unter schweren beschossen
haben die Ukraine versucht die
Schifffahrt über die Donau via Rumänien
als Alternativroute zu nutzen und damit
die Blockade ihrer schwarz mehr helfen
zu umgehen seitdem das internationale
getreideabkommen mit Russland
ausgelaufen ist droht Moskau damit jedes
ukrainische Schiff zu versenken das
versucht auszulaufen das ist nicht nur
für die Ukraine dieser strös sondern
auch für die Länder die bislang
ukrainisches Getreide importierten als
Vermittler versucht sich der türkische
Präsident Erdogan der dafür heute sogar
nach Russland reistet
erdogan hat sich viel vorgenommen er
will nicht weniger als die Hungerkrise
beenden die der Krieg in der Ukraine
verschärft hat er will derjenige sein
der der NATO und der Welt einen neuen
Getreide- präsentiert auch wenn der
Draht zu Putin schon mal besser war
ich glaube dass die Botschaft die wir
nach unserem Treffen vermitteln werden
einen wichtigen Schritt für die Welt
darstellen wird insbesondere für die
weniger entwickelten afrikanischen
Länder
Rückblick gut ein Jahr lang konnten
ukrainische Frachter gefahrlos
tonnenweise Getreide in die Welt
Verschiffen trotz des Krieges dazu hatte
sich Russland mit dem getreideabkommen
verpflichtet so wurden über Istanbul
Lebensmittel in die ärmsten Länder
Afrikas und Asiens geliefert 36
Millionen Tonnen bis der Kreml den Deal
im Juli platzen lässt
heute nach drei Stunden Verhandlungen
kein Durchbruch Putin behaart auf seiner
Version der Ereignisse
wir würden zu dieser Entscheidung
gezwungen weil westliche Länder die
Umsetzung des getreideabkommens
blockieren indem sie den Zugang
russischer Agrarprodukte zu den
Weltmärkten nicht sicherstellen
kein neuer Deal dafür mehr russisch
türkische Zusammenarbeit im Bereich
Energie und eine Million Tonnen
kostenloses Getreide für Afrika außen
vor die Ukraine Erdogan mit leiser
Kritik
auf die Tagesordnung gebrachten
Alternativvorschläge können nicht so ein
sicheres und dauerhaftes Modell bieten
wie die schwarzmeerinitiative die auf
der Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Parteien
beruhte
Russlands Getreideexporte stiegen
kräftig an im August wurden 7,7
Millionen Tonnen exportiert gut 36% mehr
als im Vorjahr
in der Ukraine aber bleiben die
Getreidespeicher voll und immer wieder
greift Russland diese an auch heute
dorthin möchte Putin die Ukraine
bekommen dass das landwirtschaftlich am
Boden liegt und die Unterstützung aus
dem Westen verloren geht denn dann
könnte es sozusagen noch was mit dem
militärischen Sieg in der langfrist
werden
ist ein Meister diplomatischer
drahtseilakte er hätte gerne seine
Freundschaft wie er sie nennt zu Putin
genutzt um der Welt einen
Verhandlungserfolg zu präsentieren doch
diesen Triumph gewährte Putin ihm heute
nicht
da fragen wir doch nach unseren
Korrespondenten in Moskau und Istanbul
am Körper in Moskau das Putin diesen
Abkommen plötzlich wieder zustimmen
würde damit war aber ja eh nicht zu
rechnen oder
damit war eigentlich nicht zu rechnen
genau und man kann sich heute Abend
durchaus die Frage stellen wozu
überhaupt dieses Treffen vielleicht die
mir Putin hat einmal mehr die große
Bühne genutzt für die immer gleichen
Bedingungen und Anschuldigungen an den
Westen ich denke das folgt einem sowohl
innen als auch außenpolitischen Kalkül
innenpolitisch führt er damit die
Antipathie gegen den besten und
außenpolitisch an die Partner im in der
Welt z.B China sagt er ich an mir liegt
doch gar nicht ich will das Abkommen
Abschließen der besten ist schuld denn
gerade china will ja auch das Getreide
aus der Ukraine haben das ganze das auch
noch der der türkische Präsident hier
heute versucht hat sich als Vermittler
zu inszenieren auch das kann man
erklären in den letzten Monaten hat es
Verstimmungen zwischen Moskau und Ankara
gegeben das z.B die Unterstützung der
Türkei für die Ukraine und wenn man
gesehen hat wie optimistisch der
türkische Präsident Erdogan heute morgen
kam und mit welch leeren Händen er nach
Hause ging und hört auch das dem Kalkül
das Vladimir Putin heute dann schauen
wir noch
istanbistisch vielleicht aber letztlich
wird das ja auch Erdogan gewusst haben
dass es da wahrscheinlich keinen großen
Durchbruch gibt es trotzdem nach Moskau
gereist welche Interessen verfolgt er
damit
also man kann vermuten dass er damit
sicher auch noch mal seine Position
sozusagen als Chef Vermittler auf der
Weltbühne festigen wollte wenn man sich
heute seine Medien also die
regierungsnahen Medien in der Türkei
angeschaut hat dann haben die die Reise
ihres Präsidenten gefeiert von einer
Niederlage oder ähnlichem war da
überhaupt nicht die Rede andererseits
hat der Erdogan wie ich denke aber auch
gar keine Alternative diese Reise
anzutreten denn er ist es sicherlich in
Abhängigkeit zu Russland beide Länder
wir haben es eben gehört die liegen zwar
bei einigen Themen vielleicht über Kreuz
aber wenn man sich jetzt mal auch nur
die Regionalkonflikte anschaut in die
die Türkei und Russland verwickelt sind
sei es in Syrien sei es in Libyen sei es
beim Konflikt zwischen Armenien und
Aserbaidschan oder eben jetzt in der
Ukraine da haben die Türkei und Russland
die sitzen da im selben Boot und das
gilt auch erst recht für ihre
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten ob es
jetzt im Energie Sektor ist in der
Rüstung in der Landwirtschaft oder im
Tourismus also Ankara und Moskau können
sich eigentlich gar nicht leisten nicht
miteinander zu sprechen und dass sie das
tun dass sie miteinander reden das
wollen ja dann letztlich alle das wollen
die Vereinten Nationen das will auch die
Ukraine und das wir leben auch der
Westen danke schön für eure Analysen aus
Moskau
für die Ukraine gibt es in diesem Krieg
aber auch Erfolgsmeldungen Treffer gegen
russische kriegslogistik Geländegewinne
Durchbrüche die wichtig sind aber nicht
notwendigerweise auch kriegsentscheidend
dafür müssten die Ukraine dann
tatsächlich tief in die besetzen Gebiete
vordringen so wie ihnen das im letzten
Sommer und Herbst gelangen als die
Russen noch nicht hunderttausende Minen
verlegt und dichte
Verteidigungsstellungen errichtet hatten
für Aufsehen sorgt dass Präsident
selenski mitten in diesem Krieg seinen
Verteidigungsminister austauscht die
Personalwahl kommt in der Ukraine aber
mehrheitlich ganz gut an Henna
Hebestreit mit Reaktionen und
Hintergründen
es ist ein Ort wie viele im Hinterland
der Front bei saporiga ukrainische
Soldaten versorgen sich mit dem was
ihnen in den letzten Tagen gefehlt hat
an denen sie vor allem damit beschäftigt
waren aus solchen hexenkesseln lebend
herauszukommen hier Kampf gegen die
russischen Aggressoren ist gnadenlos
aber sie kommen langsam voran mitten in
der entscheidenden Phase der Offensive
sorgt ihr Oberbefehlshaber für einen
ganz eigenen knall-effekt
ich habe mich entschieden den
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine zu
entlassen
olexesnikow hat mehr als 550 Tage des
Angriffskrieges durchgehalten jetzt
glaube ich dass das Ministerium einen
neuen Ansatz und andere Formen der
Zusammenarbeit braucht mit dem Militär
und der Gesellschaft
restnikowskalt schon lange als angezählt
immer wieder wurden Korruptionsfälle in
seine Ministerium bekannt ihm selbst
wird keine Vorteilsnahme vorgeworfen
dass er jetzt schriftlich um seine
Entlassung bitten muss findet aber
Zustimmung wenn ein Ministerium unter so
starken
Korruptionsvorwürfen seit Monaten unter
Druck gestellt wird dass unsere
ukrainische Journalisten das aufgespürt
haben dann ist das glaube ich eine
adäquate politische Entscheidung des
ukrainischen Präsidenten den
Verteidigungsminister auszuwechseln
Nachfolge soll der Krim Tatare Russin
omero werden ein Vertrauter des
Präsidenten und aktuell Chef des Fonds
des staatsvermögens er gilt als
durchsetzungsstark und vor allem als
unbelastet von Korruptionsvorwürfen die
Nominierung des Mannes von der Krim gilt
auch politisch als Statement
wenn jemand im Westen oder in Russland
das als ein verstärktes Signal
unseres Willens sehen will dass wir die
Halbinsel kriegen unbedingt als
unentbehrlichen Teil der ukrainischen
Souveränität und Integrität ansehen dann
bitteschön tun sie das die Soldaten
möchten sich vor der Kamera nicht äußern
ihre Themen sind russische Minen die
ihren vormar Bremsen zumindest der
Wechsel erleben wir hier nur
Schulterzucken und die Aussage man
wechselt doch keine Pferde an der
Kreuzung
gut möglich dass sie schon wieder Kopf
und Kragen riskieren wenn Ihr neuer
Minister vereidigt wird
Informationen Analysen und Videos zu
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine finden
Sie natürlich wie immer auch online auf
ZDF heute darunter auch einen Portrait
das künftigen Verteidigungsministers und
jetzt geht es erstmal bei dir weiter
Gondel damit andere Nachrichten in
Kenias Hauptstadt Nairobi ist der erste
Afrika Klimagipfel eröffnet worden der
Kontinent mit seinen rund 1,3 Milliarden
Einwohnern ist stark vom Klimawandel
betroffen und trägt im internationalen
Vergleich sehr wenig dazu bei zentrale
Forderungen mehr Geld und mehr Einfluss
für Afrika beim Klimaschutz Kenias
Präsident routo beschrieb zum Auftakt
die Chancen Afrikas bei der weltweiten
Energiewende bis Mittwoch wollen die
Gipfel Teilnehmer Ziele definieren auch
für die Weltklimakonferenz Ende November
in Dubai
die schweren Unwetter in Spanien haben
mindestens fünf Menschen das Leben
gekostet mehrere werden noch vermisst am
Wochenende waren über weite Teile
Spaniens Unwetter mit Starkregen
Orkanböen und Haare hinweggezogen was
viele ortsflüsse über die Ufer treten
ließ westlich von Madrid stürzte eine
Brücke ein zahlreiche Ortschaften aber
auch landwirtschaftliche Flächen wurden
mit Wasser und Flammen überschwemmt
nach einer erneuten Koranverbrennung ist
es in der schwedischen Stadt Malmö zu
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen gekommen in
der Nacht sein dutzende Autos in Brand
gesetzt worden so die Polizei und Beamte
in einem einwandererviertel mit Steinen
beworfen worden am Sonntag hatte ein
anti-islam Aktivist eine Koranausgabe
verbrannt eine aufgebrachte Menge hatte
versucht ihn davon abzuhalten
in der Diskussion über die Wolfsbestände
in Europa zeichnet sich eine Lockerung
der strengen eu-schutzregeln ab
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke erklärte
den Abschuss von Wölfen erleichtern zu
wollen nach rissen etwa von Schafen
Weidetiere müssten besser geschützt
werden bis Ende September will Lemke
konkrete Vorschläge vorliegen auch die
EU arbeitet an Daten zu wolfsbeständen
in ganz Europa und einer Überprüfung des
Schutzstatus dieser Rudel Tiere
bei der Diskussion um die Wölfe geht es
um Konflikte durch wieder Ansiedlung
Wölfe waren ja in unseren Wäldern
heimisch und sind es nun wieder eine
ganz andere Problematik entsteht durch
sogenannte invasive Arten die Asiatische
Tigermücke etwa hat in unseren
Breitengraden eigentlich nichts verloren
sie ist im Zuge der Globalisierung aber
trotzdem eingewandert per Flugzeug oder
Containerschiff wer weiß jedenfalls ist
sie da und das ist nicht gut
ähnliches gilt für viele Tiere aber auch
für zahlreiche Pflanzen in seinem
neuesten Bericht warnt der Welt
biodiversitätsrat vor den massiven
Schäden die invasive Arten anrichten
Andreas stammen beginnt seinen Beitrag
mit einer Pflanze die von Europäern
bewusst importiert wurde und der wir
jetzt nicht mehr werden
ein Bild sagt mehr als 1.000 Worte
darüber wie viel durch und im Kampf
gegen invasive Atem kaputt geht gegen
fieses Gestrüpp einen lautlosen
atemkiller wie sie die spätblühende
Traubenkirsche hier nennen sie verdrängt
die tötet nicht direkt das Gift macht
den anderen Pflanzen nix das ist nur ein
fraß gibt aber dadurch dass sie halt
kaum gefressen wird ach komm Insekt zum
Schädlinge hat die Pflanze kommt erstmal
bei Amerika Schwerstarbeit für die
Truppe vom Naturschutzbund NABU Ihr
Auftrag das Waldstück Hirschacker nach
Heidelberg vom Eindringling befreien die
Traubenkirsche muss raus um jeden Preis
immer auf die Wurzel Klebstoff die
richtige dann geht das hier durch ich
spürst du richtig auf dem Griff weißt
wenn es dann richtig einschlägt dass wir
auf Stein klopfen
die Traubenkirsche wurde bewusst
eingeführt als Zierpflanze für den
heimischen Garten weil sie so schön sei
nun verbreitet sich das bis zu 20 Meter
hohe Gewächs ungestört zerstört die
heimische Artenvielfalt diese Pflanze
verdrängt andere Pflanzen indem sie
quasi die Fläche durch erlaubt
hier sind ganz kleine Gras Büschel das
ist das silbergras das ist eine Art die
man hier schützen will im
Naturschutzgebiet davor ausgerottet zu
werden und eine Millionen Tieren
Pflanzenarten sind vom Aussterben
bedroht ein Hauptgrund so der am Mittag
in Bonn vorgestellte Bericht des weltbio
diversitätsrates invasive Arten die das
ökologische Gleichgewicht zerstören wir
haben zum Beispiel festgestellt dass in
60% aller Fälle wo Tiere global
ausgestorben sind invasive Arten einer
der haupttreiber war
3.500 gebietsfremde schädliche Spezies
gibt es weltweit etwa 100 davon in
Deutschland der Schaden für die normale
Wirtschaft jährlich rund 400 Milliarden
Euro größter Posten sicher Ausbreitung
neuer Krankheiten also gigantische
Gesundheitskosten für Menschen aber auch
für Nutzpflanzen oder Haustiere
Nutztiere von Menschen
zweite ganz wichtige ganz wichtiger
Punkt Störungen von Bestäubern von
samenausbreitern so dass Ernteerträge
massiv sinken durch invasive Arten und
ein dritter ein drittes Beispiel ist die
Blockade von Wasserwegen durch
eingeschleppte Wasserpflanzen die zu
beseitigen ist teuer und wie auch nahe
Heidelberg mühsam der vorgelegte Bericht
dreht zu strengen Einfuhr und
Zollkontrollen Aufklärung natürliche
Fressfeinde aussetzen am Ende auch per
Hand bekämpfen Lösungen gibt es so die
Experten doch noch werde weltweit zu
wenig getan
der Autobauer Volkswagen muss die
Produktion im Stammwerk Wolfsburg
drosseln und hat Kurzarbeit für die
betroffene Mitarbeiter beantragt drei
Wochen lang vom 11 September an
Hintergrund sind fehlende Motorteile aus
Slowenien dort hatte Hochwasser einen
Zulieferer lahmgelegt nach drei Monaten
im Plus sind
deutschlandsexporte im Juli
zurückgegangen laut Statistischen
Bundesamt sanken die Ausfuhren im
Vergleich zum Juni um 0,9% auf rund 130
Milliarden Euro die größten Abnehmer
deutscher Produkte waren andere
EU-Mitgliedstaaten
die schwache Nachfrage auf den
Weltmärkten trifft deutsche
Schlüsselindustrien wie die Autobranche
da steht die IAA mobility die morgen in
München eröffnet wird besonders im Fokus
Frank Bethmann schon vormesse beginnen
klagt die Branche über die schlechten
Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland
Hauptpunkt sind die hohen Energiekosten
die Präsidentin des Verbandes der
Automobilindustrie Hildegard Müller für
heute noch mal schweres Geschütz auf der
Standort würde aufgrund der
Kostenstrukturen dramatisch an
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verlieren man habe
so Müller weiter die höchsten
Energiekosten und in Richtung
ampelregierung ein zeitlich befristeter
industriestrompreis der nötig weil sich
sonst Industrien wie Batterie und
Halbleitertechnik gar nicht erst
ansiedeln oder abwandern würden und
bezogen auf die eigene Branche wir
entscheiden jetzt wo wir in Zukunft
Technologien investieren und deswegen
muss auch der Staat in seiner
Geschwindigkeit bei diesen Themen
zulegen kämpferische Töne auch Stefan
Hartung Stichwort Elektromobilität die
Deutschen haben ganz sicher die Chance
an die Spitze zurückzukommen derzeit
aber haben andere die Nase vorn
besonders ins Rampenlicht rücken die
chinesischen Hersteller ja es geht um
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit was wollen die
Deutschen e-autobauer denn der
chinesischen Konkurrenz entgegensetzen
ja die Ansätze sind unterschiedlich VW
setzt auf design will seinen Marken so
wieder zu mehr Wiedererkennung verhelfen
mercedes macht anders auf sich
aufmerksam bezeichnet den neuen CLA als
ein Liter Auto und stellt so die
Sparsamkeit in den Mittelpunkt der neue
CLA soll weniger als 12 Kilowattstunden
auf 100 km verbrauchen
Frank Wittmann vielen Dank für diesen
Einblick und den Ausblick
die Bundespolizei mahnt nach mehreren
Vorfällen Bahnreisende zur Vorsicht vor
manipulierten Steckdosen Entzügen diese
sollten vor Benutzung genau angeschaut
werden etwa ob Drähte oder Metallstifte
aus der Steckdose raten nach
entsprechenden Fällen bei verschiedenen
bahnanbietern bei denen Passagiere zum
Teil Stromschläge erlitten hatten
ermittelt die Polizei wegen gefährliche
und versuchte Körperverletzung
es gibt immer mehr
Hautkrebserkrankungen in Deutschland
deswegen plädieren Hautärzte für eine
staatlich organisierte Vorsorge derzeit
können gesetzlich Krankenversicherte
über 35 alle zwei Jahre kostenlos zum
Screening gehen auf eigene Initiative
der Berufsverband Deutscher Dermatologen
fordert jetzt Anschreiben an alle 35,7
Millionen Versicherte mit Einladungen
zur kostenlosen Vorsorge
die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft ist zur
Vorbereitung kommender Länderspiele in
Wolfsburg angekommen zwei Testspiele hat
das
dfb-herrenteam vor sich das erste am
Samstag gegen Japan überraschend wieder
dabei Bayern Stürmer Thomas Müller der
heute von Trainer Hansi Flick nach
nominiert wurde wegen des möglichen
Ausfalls von Niklas Füllkrug der sich
eine Sehnenzerrung zugezogen hat
was macht man wenn man sich durch einen
doofen Unfall ein blaues Auge geholt hat
und damit wieder zu arbeiten muss
natürlich erstmal allen Kollegen
versichern man habe sich keineswegs
geprügelt es gibt nun mal so
Verletzungen die sind naja nicht nur
schmerzhaft sondern irgendwie blöd oder
wie Bundeskanzler Scholz ist heute auf
Social Media formulierte wer den Schaden
hat er sah jedenfalls gespannt auf die
memes also auf die Scherze die man im
Netz nun mit seiner Augenklappe machen
werde Andreas Künast liefert ihm und uns
gleich mal eine kleine Zusammenstellung
das ist vor drei Stunden in Berlin die
erste Chance für das zweite Bild da ist
das erste Bild schon einmal um die Welt
gegangen the chainsler die champsellier
el Canti je und die Geschichte vom
Jogging Unfall in einem Dutzend Sprachen
das ist die erste Chance für den ersten
Witz Scholz ist zu Gast bei der
Bischofskonferenz er lacht aber noch
etwas gequält
das war ein Scherz aber vielleicht noch
nicht die Art mit der der
Regierungssprecher am Morgen gerechnet
hat man muss sich aufgrund der
Verletzung am Auge daran gewöhnen dass
er nächsten Tagen mit Augenklappe
auftreten wird ich freue mich über alle
nimmst die dazu in den nächsten Minuten
Stunden und Tagen mich erreichen werden
es wird ein Olaf scholz-tag in den
sozialen Medien Piraten Witze
papageienwitze
und ein Berlin kleinmachnowitz
er war heute morgen ganz gut gelaunt
sieht aber noch etwas ramponiert aus
wird aber alle Termine die geplant sind
wahrnehmen am Abend beim Sommerfest
Termin der spd-zeitung vorwärts wollen
alle Olafs Verfassung sehen und über
Olafs Verfassung reden der einzige der
sie mit keinem Wort erwähnt ist Olaf
übrigens das Gefühl heute werden mehr
Fotos gemacht als sonst weiß nicht woran
das liegt
Olaf Fotos sind das Ding des Tages das
schlimme ist nicht dass heute kein Gag
ausgelassen wird
sondern dass das jetzt noch eine
vielleicht zwei Wochen so weitergeht
das war es von uns mit dem montagskino
jetzt gleich weiter und schon um 23:40
Uhr meldet sich Nazan gökte mir mit
unserem heute journal Update und wir
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses
umfangreiche hoch sorgt bei uns für sehr
ruhiges der sonniges Wetter aber auf
seiner Ostseite rauscht die Kaltluft bis
in den Mittelmeerraum und erreicht
Griechenland hier ist das Mittelmeer
aufgeheizt und in dieser aufgeheizten
Stimmung kommt die Kaltluft voran sorgt
für extreme Regenmengen bei Gewittern
und die sind bei 700 Liter pro
Quadratmeter angesiedelt punktuell
können es sogar über 1000 Liter werden
und das ist katastrophal da muss muss
man mit teilweise heftigen
Überschwemmungen und Schlammlawinen
rechnen bei uns dagegen komplett ruhiges
Wetter als sternenklar teils bildet sich
Nebel bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 9
Grad im Südosten und 16 Grad zum
Beispiel ganz im Westen Deutschlands
morgen dann von der Früh weg viel
Sonnenschein nur im Osten gibt's einige
wenige Wolken insgesamt ist es trocken
und die Temperaturen steigen bis auf 30
31 Grad ganz im Westen Deutschlands
entlang des Rheins und 24 Grad an der
Nordsee aber schauen Sie hier auch in
der norddeutschen Tiefebene liegen die
Werte bei 29 Grad und auch die nächsten
Tage Sonnenschein pur und das bei Werten
von 25 bis 31 Grad am Mittwoch
Donnerstag und Freitag in der Spitze bis
32 Grad und weiterhin viel Sonne damit
ein schöner Abend